كما اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال بمدينه جنين
حاجز الجلمه بالضفه الغربيه حيث اطلق
مقاومون فلسطينيون النار على قوات
الاحتلال خلال اقتحامها المدينه معززه ب
20 دوريه عسكريه وتردد دوي اشتباكات
وانفجارات قويه وانتشرت الاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه في محيط دوار الجلبوني وسط
جنين حتى
اللحظه معنا من جنين مراسله الجزيره جيفار
البديري وضع حاليا في جنين وكذا ذلك ما
الذي يبرر اقتحام محلات صرافه
تحديدا الان الوضع الميداني لنبدا به
مياده واضح اننا امام انسحاب جزئي لقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من كامل مدينه جنين
ولكن حتى اللحظه نحن بانتظار تاكيدات
رسميه بان بالفعل الجيش انسحب
بالكامل لانه لم يتم حتى اللحظه الاعلان
الرسمي الاسرائيلي بانه تم الانسحاب من
المدينه لانه ايضا تبقى الخشيه من القناصه
والوحدات الخاصه بعد ان كانت قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قد نشرت العشرات من
جنود القناصه على كثير من اسطح البنايات
السكنيه المطله على وسط مدينه جنين حيث
نتواجد الان هنا كانت احدى اهم مسارح
العمليات العسكريه حيث كان منذ انتصاف
الليل حتى قبل حوالي العشر دقائق العديد
من الاليات العسكريه سواء الصغيره او
الكبيره ومن بين المحال التي تم
استهدافها احد محلات الصرافه في هذه
البنايه فيما يعرف ببرج الساعه وهو واحد
من اكبر واهم محلات الصرافه هذا المشهد
تكرر في كل انحاء الضفه
الغربيه منذ انتصاف الليل حتى ساعات الفجر
الاولى نتحدث عن مدن جنين طول كرم اريحا
نابلس ايضا في مدينه رام الله وفي الخليل
وفي مدينه رام الله كما ذكرت استشهد شاب
فلسطيني جار فقط سانوه بهذا الخبر العاجل
المرتبط بما كنت تتحد حدثين عنه هيئه البث
الاسرائيليه عن وزيره الدفاع تنقل انه تم
تصنيف خمس محلات صرافه في الضفه الغربيه
على انها ارهابيه وتم مصادره 10 ملايين
شيكل منها تفضلي
جيفار هذا نعم هذا ما كنت اود الحديث عنه
بانه نقلا عن اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي فان
قوات الاحتلال ووفق بيان رسمي تقول انها
اي قامت
بمداهمة الصرافه و بزعم انها تدعم عمليات
ارهابيه وتم مصادره مبلغ وهو 10 ملايين
شيكل اي بما يعادل تقريبا 3 ملايين دولار
امريكي من هذه المحال سواء من محال صرافه
في الضفه الغربيه او من داخل منازل لانه
كان هناك تاكيدات من عدد من الاهالي من
مناطق عده في الضفه الغربيه ب انه تم
مداهمه منازل وتم بالقوه اخذ خزنات او
خزنه للاموال
اي هذه الخزنه قد تكون شخصيه ل رجل اعمال
او لبعض المهتمين بالاحتفاظ باموالهم داخل
منازلهم ولكن واضح ان العمليه العسكريه
بشكلها العام الخارجي كانت تستهدف محلات
الصرافه في كل انحاء الض الضفه الغربيه
اللافت كان اكثر من امر في هذه الليله
وحتى ساعات الصباح الاولى ان العمليه
العسكريه كانت تستهدف محلات الصرافه كما
هو معلوم قوات الاحتلال تزعم دائما ان
هناك عدد من هذه المحال تقوم ب تسهيل نقل
اموال سواء لحركه حماس او لحركه ال الجهاد
الاسلامي وايضا لفصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه نقل اموال قطاع غزه او استرداد
اموال او ارسالها الى الخارج رغم انه هناك
تاكيدات بان هذه المحال تملك الاوراق
الثبوتيه بذلك ولكن واضح ايضا انه في ظل
الوضع الاقتصادي الصعب جدا اصبح الان في
كامل انحاء الضفه الغربيه من منع العمال
من العوده الى اعمالهم في داخل الخط
الاخضر معظم المحال التجاريه المطاعم
المحلات يعني كل شيء في المدن الضفه
الغربيه ان دخلتيها الان ستجدينها مغلقه
لانه لا يوجد اصلا حركه للناس هي حركه
خفيفه لا يوجد تنقل بين المدن والقرى
والبلدات لانها اصبحت كتوت معزوله
وبالتالي لا يوجد حركه تجاريه يمكن ان
تساهم في تشغيل الاقتصاد الفلسطيني الامر
الثالث هو استيلاء قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي على اموال المقاصه اموال
عائدات الضرائب التي وفق بروتوكول باريس
الاقتصادي على اسرائيل ان هذه اموال
فلسطينيه وبالتالي عليها ان تسلمها قامت
اسرائيل خلال الشهرين الماضيين بوضع شروط
جديده لتسليم هذه الاموال بعدم ارسال
مستحقات قطاع غزه لدفع فواتير المياه
والكهرباء ورواتب الموظفين ايضا الموظفين
هنا في في الضفه الغربيه لان السلطه
الفلسطينيه رفضت الشروط الاسرائيليه بما
فيها الشرط المتواصل وهو عائدات او مخصصات
عائلات الاسرى والشهداء بانها لن تلتزم
بالقرار الاسرائيلي بعدم صرف مخصصاتهم
فقام الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بالسيطره على
هذه الاموال وبالتالي لم يعد هناك حتى
رواتب للموظفين
وا واضح اننا يعني كنا هذه الليله امام
حرب جديده هي حرب اقتصاد ولكن بشكل علني
كما نرى الان مياده هذا مخبز ومطعم هو ليس
لا بمحل صرافه ولا بمحل له علاقه بالاموال
هو فقط مطعم كما ترين الزجاج يعني ان قام
احد بالاقتراب منه سيتحطم بالكامل هذا
نتيجه ما قام به جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بعد انتصاف الليل سواء باطلاق النار على
كل من يتحرك او من خلال الاشتباكات
المسلحه بعد ان حاول مقاومون فلسطينيون
التصدي لهذه القوات التي اقتحمت مدينه
جنين وايضا العبوات الناسفه ولكن هذا
المحل تحديدا لاننا يعني نحن كنا في هذه
المنطقه كنا نرى من الاعلى كيف يتحرك
الجنود ويطلقون النار على كل شيء على سواء
على الاشخاص الذين يمكن ان يتحركوا او حتى
على المحل و هذا المشهد تكرر في كل انحاء
الضفه الغربيه بمحافظتها من اقصى شمال
الضفه الغربيه حتى اقصى جنوبها